de nouvelles informations font surface
dans le cadre du scandale des compteurs
d'eau
je rejoue avec plaisir l'animatrice de
l'émission enquête marie maude denis
marie maude vous avez eu accès aux
documents que l'upac a utilisé pour
mener ces perquisitions
oui une dizaine de perquisitions qui ont
eu lieu en juillet rappelez-vous patrice
les policiers de l'upac s'étaient
présentés notamment j'ai claude dauphin
le maire l'arrondissement lachine chez
francine sénécal sammy forcillo ainsi
que cosmo match ocha qui étaient tous
d'anciens membres du comité exécutif de
la ville de montréal sous gerald
tremblay et pendant la période
d'attribution du contrat des compteurs
d'eau
alors bien sûr on ce qu'on apprend dans
ses mandats de perquisition là c'est que
les quatre sont soupçonnées d'abus de
confiance
ils sont clairement suspects de cette
enquête sur les compteurs d'eau
est ce qu'on découvre dans les documents
c'est que les quatre ans et mende comité
exécutif aurait eu plusieurs rencontres
sociales on parle de souper déjeuner
longues parfois dans les meilleurs
restaurants de la ville
l'âge au centre bell qui pour voir
madonna qui pour voir des parties de
hockey et aussi un barbecue chez frank
zampino et des super de noël chez paolo
catania et d'autres dirigeants de firmes
qui étaient en lice pour le contrat des
compteurs d'eau et sa patrie s'il faut
comprendre que pendant tout le processus
d'attribution du contrat donc de 2006 à
2008 il y avait une règle très clair les
soumissionnaires ce qui vous qui êtes en
compétition pour ce contrat ne pouvait
pas communiquer avec des élus avec des
fonctionnaires toute personne
responsable de l'attribution de ce
contrat alors on a attrapé claude
dauphin il y à quelques minutes il a
réagi voici ce qu'il avait à dire
puis quand j'étais président du comité
exécutif la seule fois où je suis
intervenu dans ce dossier là pour les
nuls et et clément tremblay fait je vous
répète le dossier des compteurs d'eau ni
de près ni de loin mon sujet m'occuper
de mon mari mon en conclusion on parle
dans les mêmes documents
clairement de partage de contrats à la
ville de montréal
absolument et on mentionne que tendent
au fake fortios sénécal match ocha
fréquentait des personnes liées au
système de partage du contrat
installé à montréal on mentionne rosaire
sauriol de dessau et bernard poulin de
du groupe inseme faut savoir patrice que
ces documents là je vous le répète ça
veut pas dire que ces gens là sont
accusés ça ne veut pas dire que ces
faits là sont vraies ce sont les
allégations de l'enquète faudra voir
s'il ya des accusations qui vont suivre
ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas pour le
moment marie maude on vous salue rentrée
pour l'émission enquête jeudi rapidement
le quelle date le 10 septembre à
septembre ce rendez vous merci merci au
revoir